please Chef I want to go out the first
episode of the new Silo series opens
with a voiceover of the character
Sheriff Holston as we watch him getting
ready to leave his apartment in that he
lays out the reality of what it's like
living in The Silo saying we do not know
why we are here we do not know who built
the silo we do not know why everything
outside The Silo is as it is we do not
know when it will be safe to go outside
we only know that that day is not this
day it's a lot of questions to have
related to the basic history of a
community that was so clearly planned
out that also understands itself to be
made up of the last 10 000 people on
Earth apparently there was a rebellion
140 years ago that's responsible for
their history being erased but as the
sheriff's wife Allison points out things
don't exactly add up if the rebels
destroying their history was such a bad
thing why why do the people in charge
restrict things like relics that are
connected to their past it's suspicious
but we see that the people who live
there have an investment in believing
the story as evidenced by the Freedom
Day celebration the one thing they know
for sure is that the world outside is
toxic and as far as they can tell
there's no safe way to explore it that
adds a dystopian flavor on top of
everything else and makes it very
surprising when the sheriff who comes
off as a by the book straight shooter
declares that he wants to go out this is
the Cardinal law of the society that
lives there any spoken request to leave
The Silo is granted but it's irrevocable
once uttered it's determinative in other
words it's a death sentence and Deputy
Mars's reaction to holston's declaration
underlines the severity of what he heard
perfectly a couple of details to know
about the silo are that it's broken up
into three sections of 48 floors each
they're known as the up top where most
of the characters we meet in the
beginning live the mids in the Middle
where Allison goes to meet fellow
computer geek George and the down deep
at the bottom where Holston meets Juliet
at the end the story takes place at some
point in the future with people who
appear to be descendants of Americans
they have access to some technology so
some things about how The Silo was
designed or strange like how it doesn't
have any elevators and it takes an
entire day to walk the levels from the
top to the bottom this has an effect of
localizing things between the different
sections people from the up top rarely
visit the down deep without a good
reason and vice versa and there's some
otherization that goes along with that
even with such a small population there
are divisions it's not as Extreme as
something like snow piercer if you're
familiar with that but the groups do in
a way see themselves as different types
of people perhaps an oversimplification
that works well enough is to say that
the people in the down deep see
themselves as the working class whose
labor is the backbone that keeps things
running and people from the up top see
themselves as a higher class of people
who do the important jobs there isn't a
huge disparity in quality of life though
so more than anything it's a situation
where each group thinks that theirs is
the quintessential role in The Silo and
that it would fall into chaos if they
weren't there to keep it going I've read
this series as it exists in its current
form of three novels titled wool shift
and dust the first season of the show
covers about the first half of wool and
it becomes apparent fairly quickly how
the name is connected to what's going on
as the phrase pull the wool over your
eyes comes to mind the other will
reference is that the cloth they use to
clean is made out of it but in the
recent AMA the author did he mentioned
that he included that detail as a way to
keep things obscure I'll say that I
enjoyed the this series overall but what
made me excited to see an adaptation was
that Hugh Howie's original series leans
heavily toward plot in a lot of ways the
main character is The Silo itself and
how it got there rather than the people
who live inside and push to understand
the answers to those questions this
isn't a bad thing the author had some
interesting ideas he wanted to explore
and does a good job of doing that but
the television format opens the door to
further develop these characters along
the way I think episode 1 is a great
example of how that could work because
the two characters we spend the most
time with just have this short
appearance Holston and Allison in their
situation are there to introduce us to
the world and give us an idea of what
life is like inside this Silo in the
episode's opening we find out that
neither of them will live to be the main
character in the story but we still get
to spend some time with them and get to
know them knowing them helps us
understand each subsequent character we
meet and how they experience life in
this strange setting through them we
also get a better idea about the rules
and that there are restrictions on who
can have children even though they had
two unsuccessful attempts before they've
been approved for a third through a
lottery they have a year to try to
conceive and we watch as her mandated
birth control devices removed
she works in I.T which is something that
we'll learn more about in the future and
she has a rebellious streak that her
boss Bernard doesn't appreciate now
she's talking to her husband we get some
details about why things are the way
they are as a law man he's unsympathetic
to any of his wife's talk about
questioning the rules and mentions that
something called The Pact is the only
history they have and he's not exactly
wrong they know people that go outside
to clean do die as a result and when we
meet the mayor we also see that if no
one goes out to do that it starts to get
hard to see what the outside looks like
The Pact and the rules appear to be
necessary to keep order in a place where
space is limited and where they do
essentially have everything they need
giving up some control doesn't feel like
too high of a price to pay a woman named
Gloria who comes off as conspiracy
minded gets Allison's attention when she
asks if she thinks she's the kind the
person they want having children by the
look on her face you can tell this is
something that hadn't occurred to her
but we've seen that for all intents and
purposes they're doing their best to try
to get pregnant and it's not working
Holston thinks this is ridiculous and
threatens to send the psych team to pay
Gloria a visit for making his wife upset
from his point of view all of these
questions are senseless but the stress
of the year they spent trying to
conceive and her meeting with George who
shows her a particularly restricted
relic of a hard drive from before the
Rebellion has started to make Allison
question what she can believe we'll
learn more about relics and how they're
regulated as things progress but the
idea that she could be sent outside for
looking at this tribe makes Allison
hesitant At first she eventually gives
in and looks at the files where she
finds footage that shows that the world
outside looks very different than what
they've seen on the screens I guess I
should point point out that even though
it looks like a big window looking out
into the world in the cafeteria it's
actually a large screen all of the
floors of The Silo are underground and
what they clean when they go outside are
sensors on a small tower that sticks up
above the ground Allison also learns
that they never took her birth control
device out and those two things together
make her decide that the only way to
prove that the destruction outside is a
lie is to go out herself before she left
she told her husband that if the world
is actually green like she believes then
she'll clean if not then she'll walk
away so when Holston sees her clean it's
confirmation that there's something
going on out there that the world looks
different than what they've seen their
entire lives but then he's devastated to
see that his wife still dies moments
after she confirms that from there we
skip ahead to two years later and see
marns tell Holston that George the
programmer that Allison was working with
who had also transferred out of I.T to
work in mechanical has been found dead
and it appears that he committed suicide
by going over the railing on level 120.
although Mars tells him that one of the
engineers in the down deep insists that
it was murder so the two of them take a
trip down to Mechanical to meet Juliet
who is an engineer and they find her
busy at work working on the generator
the episode ends with one more jump
forward to the present where we go back
to the holding cell where Holston went
in the beginning of the episode and hear
him explain to Mars that he's going
outside to find Allison even though they
can see her dead body laying there right
on the screen that's displayed on the
wall the second episode opens with
technicians getting ready to send him
out you see them preparing his suit you
see mayor Johns and Deputy marns going
through the same motions that he went
through when he was sending Allison out
and he apologizes to them for all the
fuss when he gets outside he sees that
same Lush landscape that she saw with
the same birds flying by that you saw
reflected in her glasses while she was
watching the file that was marked Jean
comedy cleaning with George he takes
this as a sign that she was right and
says to himself they have to see then he
does what everyone else before him has
done he cleans the sensors and then he
goes to walk away when we see things
from his perspective his wife's body is
missing from the hill in front of him
but when he starts to die he takes his
helmet off and then you see him start to
crawl directly to her body so that
they'll rest together so when you put
two and two together you realize that
the Lush landscape is what you see
inside the helmet it's implied that it's
there to get people who all say they
won't do it to clean Allison seeing this
on the computer first was convinced that
it meant the truth was being hidden from
them and her signaling to Holston that
it was true got him to follow her out
there but they both still died which
means the air is toxic and as far as you
can tell what the people see on the
screens is how things really look out
there this changes the question from
what's going on when people go outside
to who set this up this way and why in
his office Mars opens the letter that
Holston left for him and we'll find out
later that it says that he wants Juliet
to be his replacement the mayor was
expecting him to step into the role but
he says he's retiring and he keeps
holston's pick a secret for the time
being there's a real concern about
stability now that the sheriff is gone
and you see some fear amongst the
population Who start arming themselves
you also get introduced briefly to the
character Sims who works for judicial
who come off as an intelligence service
that operate independently from the
sheriff's office we watch as Juliet
freaks out after she saw Holston die and
she leaves the cafeteria calling him a
liar later she'll tell her friend Martha
who has a workshop where she's been
hanging around since she's was a kid she
doesn't believe George killed himself
because the last time she saw him he was
excited about something he told her that
he had something to tell her and then he
left a Pez dispenser Relic with a note
that said that he had found what he was
looking for in her room the morning
after she receives this she finds out he
dies so they never see each other again
and because they weren't in a sanctioned
relationship it's not easy for her to
explain why she's so sure he was
murdered but the local Deputy agrees to
send her concerns to the sheriff anyway
Holston does decide to come and look
into it at that time which was a few
months before his death when pressed she
shows him the Pez dispenser and the half
of the note that says remember the last
place you saw this then she takes him to
an underground chamber that nobody is
supposed to know about it's massive and
houses what she thinks is the machine
that excavated The Silo in the first
place according to Legend after it digs
that far down there's no easy way to get
it out so so the founders just walled it
off with 30 feet of concrete if you go
back and look at the scene where he's
looking at the plans for The Silo on his
computer you can see where that is I
should mention that all of this is added
for the show in the book the excavator
is introduced with the same line that
she says about bearing it but it's from
a different character in a completely
different context and there you never
really get to see the relationship
Holston and Juliet have the scenes that
they share here make his choice to pick
her as his successor make a lot more
sense and I think this is all a big
Improvement when she discovers that
George hid the hard drive for her she
discovers why Holston was interested in
coming down to look into the case he
tells her that his wife did some it work
for George just before she went out and
this is where things start to get
interesting and everything starts to
make sense there's a great back and
forth here where Juliet is upset because
he didn't tell her about George's
connection to Allison and she starts to
worry that it's going to affect how she
handles his case she says she wants him
to do his job which she says is to find
the truth but he counters this saying
that it's actually to maintain order in
The Silo so at first he's adamant that
he needs to destroy the drive and then
she says maybe if he had listened to his
wife she'd still be alive this ties back
to the conversation he had with Allison
where she tells him that talking isn't
listening which was right after she
removed her birth control and then what
he said to Mars about he should have
followed her out three years ago but he
couldn't listen this all gets him to
change his mind but there isn't much
that he can do publicly so he tells her
to keep her head down and that he'll
send her a sign and that she'll know
what it is when she sees it then we go
back to her talking to Margaret where
she says that that's what she did and
she never got her answers so that's why
she called him a liar whenever she saw
him die she also shows her the other
half of the note she never showed the
share of and then leaves to go to try to
find out what George found elsewhere
marns eventually shows the mayor
holston's last request to make Juliet a
successor and to give her his badge even
if she refuses he thinks this just goes
to show that Holston wasn't in his right
mind before he died but she still wants
to meet Juliet so they decide to walk
the 144 levels to see her which I guess
we'll see in the next episode this
episode ends with Juliet returning to
George's hiding place where we see a
brief flashback of their time together
in their conversation he tells her that
he's looking for a door which he thinks
leads to the tunnel and that it's under
the water she tries to overcome her fear
and use the rope he left behind to
explore herself but it cuts the black
after she almost falls into the water
and watches her light sink to the bottom
I think this was a really solid start to
an adaptation of a story that I think
has a lot of potential there are quite a
few changes but most of them seem to be
related to making this into a TV show
one example that stands out when I first
read it I thought of The Silo being a
lot more claustrophobic especially the
staircases here everything seems a lot
more wide open but that also looks a lot
better for TV there's little things like
there being a screen down a mechanical
and they all sort of wear regular
clothes instead of coveralls which is
what they wear in the book but none of
these things feel like they
fundamentally change the story and if
you're wondering the author of the books
was involved with the writer's room and
from what I understand he suggested a
lot of these changes including the ones
that really add a lot to the story like
the time that Holston and Juliet spend
together one of the things I liked about
these books was that they do answer all
the questions they ask and those
Revelations come at a fairly consistent
Pace as the story develops looking at
just these two episodes I like how they
set those Mysteries up I can tell you
that if you know what to look for there
are a ton of Easter eggs and visual cues
in every scene although it's not
necessarily a puzzle to solve as much as
a lot of these things will really pop
out to you on a re-watch Juliet is
definitely the main character which
means there is a lot riding on Rebecca
Ferguson's performance and I think she's
doing a great job so far since I
basically know what will happen I can't
do any speculation in good faith and
should probably leave it there but I'd
be very interested to know what you're
thinking about after you watch these two
episodes in the comments please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon